bonjour je suis adrien barbet et j'ai
consacré mes recherches au tour de
france cycliste dans les actualités
cinématographiques et à la télévision
quand on pense au tour de france on
pense immédiatement à la télévision
c'est en effet aujourd'hui le principal
média de diffusion de l'épreuve en
france et à l'étranger
pourtant bien avant le journal télévisé
c'est au cinéma que les français
découvrent l'actualité en images
diffusés en première partie de programme
avant le film les actualités rendent
compte de cette incontournable
feuilleton estival qu'est le tour je me
suis concentré sur les décennies
d'après-guerre dans une france des
trente glorieuses qui connaît
d'importantes transformations les récits
film et hésite entre d'une part
nostalgie du passé et d'autre part
célébration des progrès contemporain au
cinéma comme à la télévision
les opérateurs se plaisent à filmer une
france rurale pittoresque folkloriser
déjà vieux de 50 ans
le tour de france est en quelque sorte
le point de repères rassurants d'une
société en plein bouleversement
ce n'est pas un hasard si raymond
poulidor représentants du noble famille
de paysans limousin est le coureur le
plus populaire des années 60 il y en a
en effet raymond poulidor n'étais qu'un
coureur de village il était connu dans
sa haute vienne mais maintenant il est
connu sur le plan international et
lorsqu'il rentre chez lui c'est
évidemment en héros qu'il est accueilli
le tour de france demeure un miroir de
son époque
le tour c'est avant tout le mois de
juillet le temps du loisir de la détente
dans le contexte d'une démocratisation
du départ en vacances les reportages du
tour font la promotion de qualité
touristique de la france
on se délecte alors du bain des coureurs
qui harassés par la chaleur se jette
dans la mer méditerranée en 1950
c'est aussi l'époque où le tour de
france connaît des incursions à
l'étranger la grande boucle suit les
évolutions de la construction européenne
voir les deux ans
la rentrée en france le lendemain se
fait par le manceau l'espagnol devra
monter ça lâchait tout le monde et les
douaniers en quelque chose à déclarer
leur enthousiasme
enfin la modernité c'est la télévision
alors qu'elle supplante peu à peu la
presse filmée la rtf radiodiffusion
télévision française jouit d'un grand
prestige le tour de france est alors le
théâtre de grands d'expérimentations
techniques avec par exemple deux
superbes prises de vue aériennes ou
encore la retransmission de l'étape le
soir-même puis en direct
c'est ainsi que depuis cette époque les
hommes de télévision font pleinement
partie de la légende
ils servent d'intermédiaires entre les
français et les héros du tour
pour le meilleur comme pour le pire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]